advisor's vaccine application for kids
under the age of five
and then i'll cover operational planning
so that we're ready for that age group
with that over to dr wilinski dr
wolinski
thank you jeff good afternoon i'd like
to start by walking you through today's
data
the current seven day daily average of
cases is about four hundred forty six
thousand four hundred cases per day a
decrease of about thirty six percent
over the previous week
the seven day average of hospital
admissions is about 17 100 per day also
a decrease of about 14 percent over the
previous week
and the seven-day average daily deaths
are about 2300 per day which is an
increase of about four percent over the
prior week
while we continue to see large decreases
in average daily case counts across the
country
hospitalizations remain high stretching
our healthcare capacity and workforce to
its limits in some areas of the country
and daily deaths also remain quite high
and with the mixed news above similar to
other waves during the pandemic our data
continue to reinforce the critical
importance of vaccination
last week i shared data from our
surveillance studies demonstrating the
effectiveness of vaccination including
boosters on decreasing cases emergency
department visits and hospitalizations
additional new data continue to support
these findings
on this slide you can see data from 25
u.s jurisdictions that report cases and
deaths linked to vaccination status
similar to what i showed you last week
vaccination and booster doses
substantially decreased the risk of
death from covet 19.
looking at the data from the week ending
december 4th the number of average
weekly deaths for those who were
unvaccinated was 9.7 per hundred
thousand people but only 0.7 per 100 000
people for those who were vaccinated
this means the risk of dying from coven
19 was 14 times higher for people who
were unvaccinated compared to those who
received only a primary series
for those who were boosted the average
of weekly deaths was 0.1 per 100 000
people
meaning that unvaccinated individuals
were 97 times more likely to die
compared to those who were boosted
i also want to share new data from cdc's
covid net hospital surveillance network
to further show how essential
vaccination and boosting is in
preventing hospitalization from covet
19.
on this slide you can see data comparing
the percentage of people aged 65 and
older who are unvaccinated and boosted
in the general population in blue and
those who are hospitalized in green
as shown on the slide only 12
of those age 65 and over remain
unvaccinated in the general population
but when we look at those over the age
of 65 who are in the hospital for covet
19
54
are unvaccinated
in stark contrast now let's look at
those who have been boosted on the
bottom
here 57
of those over age 65 are boosted in the
general population
and only 8
of those over the age of 65 and in the
hospital for cova 19 have received a
booster dose
these same trends are seen across all
age groups
these data show us that the percent of
people who are currently hospitalized
due to cover 19 are disproportionately
unvaccinated and disproportionately not
boosted
additionally these data confirm that
vaccination and boosting continue to
protect against severe illness and
hospitalization even during the omicron
surge
if you are not up to date on your coven
19 vaccinations you have not optimized
your protection against severe disease
and death and you should get vaccinated
and boosted if you are eligible thank
you i'll now turn it over to dr fauci
thank you very much dr wolinski what i
like to do over the next couple of
minutes is to address
a common misperception
and the result of
misinformation and that is
whether vaccination negatively impacts
people trying to conceive namely does it
have a negative impact
on fertility
the data are clear
next slide i will show a couple of
representative studies this
published just a week and a half ago
in the american journal of epidemiology
which is a prospective cohort study
of vaccination and sars infection and
fertility
the study is an nih-funded pregnancy
study online or presto for short
of couples who are trying to conceive
through intercourse
it enrolled participants before
pregnancy
and collected data on vaccination and
other variables during the preconception
period
and then collected data on subsequent
fertility
there were over 2 000 females between
the ages of 21 and 45 in the us or
canada
they were enrolled between december 2020
and september 2021
and they were followed through november
2021
next slide
the data were clear covert 19
vaccination in male or female partners
did not affect
the likelihood of conception
couples were 18
less likely to conceive
if
the male partner had been infected
with sars cov2 within 60 days
before a menstrual cycle that is
infected
not vaccinated however
the covert 19 disease only temporarily
reduced male fertility next slide
in another study
published again
about a week and a half ago
this was in an in vitro fertilization
clinic
and the question that was asked that
were people vaccinated in this case
either with the pfizer or the moderna
product
had similar responses
to ovarian stimulation which is used
to stimulate the ovary in preparation
for in vitro fertilization
and similar pregnancy outcomes
compared with unvaccinated people
the reproductive potential
does not appear to be affected by
vaccination
in people who undergo in vitro
fertilization next slide
so what's our takeaway
message about vaccination
and conception
new data add to previous studies that
indicate that cover 19 vaccination
does not negatively impact fertility
cdc and professional medical
organizations
serving people of reproductive aid
emphasize
as shown on this website
that there's no evidence that
vaccination impairs fertility
and of course as we've all said over and
over again
vaccination is recommended for people
who are trying to get pregnant now
or might become pregnant in the future
as well as their partners
and anyone who's vaccinated and pregnant
breastfeeding trying to get pregnant now
or might become pregnant in the future
should also
get a booster shot
when eligible final slide
the message is the same
get vaccinated and get boosted for so
many reasons
now over to you dr murthy
well thank you so much dr fauci and it's
good to be with everyone again today
as many of you know the fda has now
received pfizer's application
for a vaccine for children aged six
months through four years now jeff is
going to talk more about how we're
preparing for the possibility of this
milestone but first i want to walk you
through the process pfizer's application
will now undergo the same independent
rigorous and transparent review process
that was used to authorize the vaccines
that now more than 250 million americans
have received including millions of
children ages 5 and up it will involve
the fda receiving the full data from
pfizer posting that data publicly and
then convening its advisory committee
for a transparent discussion of the data
the fda will then render its opinion
after which the cdc and its advisory
group will assess the data and make
their recommendation this is the same
rigorous process that was used to assess
numerous vaccines long before the
pandemic began
i know how eager parents and caregivers
are for the good news on this front
for much of this pandemic millions of
parents have carried with them an added
layer of worry knowing that their
children under five didn't have
protection from kobet the way older
vaccinated children do
i felt this worry too as the father of a
four-year-old daughter who is not yet
eligible to get vaccinated
that's why i'm hopeful that we may be
one step closer to having an added layer
of protection for our younger children
and one less worry for their parents a
vaccine for children under five would
mean we would have vaccines available
for essentially all age groups in
america this would be a major milestone
now there are a number of steps ahead to
determine if the vaccine is both safe
and effective for our kids under five
and please know that the fda will not
cut any corners in their review process
they know that they are the gold
standard that all of us rely on
if and when the fda and cdc decide to
move forward we will work closely with
our trusted community partners to ensure
that families have accurate
science-based information about the
vaccine so they can make the best
decisions for their children and as we
await this review process i want to
emphasize once more just how important
it is that the rest of us get vaccinated
and get our kids five and older who are
already eligible vaccinated as well if
you are 12 and up and you're vaccinated
please get boosted as soon as you're
eligible and all of us should wear high
quality masks when in public indoor
settings this is how we can continue to
create a wall of protection around our
children under five as we look to
safeguard their health thanks so much
for your time today i'll pass it to jeff
well thanks doctors if the fda
authorizes and cdc recommends this
vaccine 18 million children
under the age of five will become
eligible for protection from carbon 19.
before we open up the questions i want
to share how we're preparing now just as
we did with vaccines for kids ages 5 to
11. so that we are ready
and we hit the ground running following
decisions from fda and cdc
importantly this vaccine is specifically
formulated for kids under the age of
five
so we're working closely with states
local health departments
pediatricians families doctors
and pharmacies to ensure the vaccine is
available at thousands of locations
nationwide
we've already secured ample doses
and the necessary needles and supplies
specially made for kids in this age
group
following fda authorization we would
immediately begin packing and shipping
doses
to states and healthcare providers and
in short order following cdc
recommendations
parents will be able to get their kids
under five vaccinated at convenient
locations
locations they know and trust
while we know many parents are eager to
get their kids the protection of the
vaccine
we know others have questions
so we're working with our partners to
ensure all parents have access to the
facts
and information they need to make the
right decision
and as always we're laser focused on
equity
and making sure we reach the hardest hit
in most at risk communities and families
a year ago we stood up a historic
nationwide vaccination program that's
now gotten 75 adults in the u.s fully
vaccinated
we then launched a boosters program
that's gotten almost 90 million
americans their booster shot
and we established a vaccination program
specifically for kids ages 5 to 11 that
has protected millions of kids around
the country
now with a potential vaccine for kids
under 5 on the horizon
our message to parents and families is
simple
we're doing everything we can to prepare
now
we're taking all of the best practices
and applying all the lessons learned
over the last 12 months
to ensure getting kids under 5 the
protection of vaccine is easy and
convenient
and we'll be ready to start getting
shots and arms soon after fda and cdc
make their decisions
with that let's open it up for some
questions
kevin
thanks jeff uh we have time for a few
questions please keep your questions to
one uh first let's go to laura santonium
at pbs
thanks so much um thinking about uh long
covert treatment can you tell me some
sort of uh latest updates with uh with
research about uh treatment availability
and um an accreditation of clinics
offering that treatment
dr fauci long kova treatments
yeah there is a very large study that's
been initiated some time ago
the recover study
at the nih in collaboration with other
agencies looking at
the incidence the prevalence
and hopefully understanding the
pathogenic mechanisms of long covid
right now the data are starting to come
in it's too early to make any definitive
statements
but for those individuals and as you
know long covert means the persistence
of signs and symptoms
that are not explainable by any red
readily recognizable pathogenic process
following the recovery from the acute
infection there have been subjects some
suggestions
that it is an aberrant inflammatory
response perhaps some element of
autoimmunity perhaps some element
of persistence of nucleotide fragments
from the virus all of these now
are being actively pursued
but before we can make any definitive
statements we need to learn a lot more
about it but the ultimate goal
of figuring out how we might be able to
mitigate or prevent some of those
symptoms thank you
next question please
let's go to jeff mason at reuters
uh thank you my question is about the
the data and about habits the with
regard to data
for dr faucio or dr wolenski what is
your take on why the booster rate seems
to be
lagging why would people who have
decided to get
vaccinated first and second doses not be
getting
more boosters and and secondly with
regard to your
uh the the data the data today with
cases going down and hospitalizations
going down dr lewinsky willenski do you
think people
should start to
change their habits and it's okay now to
maybe gather in groups more to go out to
bars and restaurants or what is the
overall guidance right now in terms of
in terms of gathering in groups jeff
this is jeff why don't we just start
with the baseline on where we are in the
booster data
and that is that about half of all
americans who are eligible
for a booster have gotten a booster
eligibility is five months or greater
for the mrna vaccines pfizer
and moderna in two months for j and j
and importantly about 70 percent
of
seniors those over
65 have gotten a booster as you know
boosters are widely available they're at
convenient locations around the country
and they're free
and obviously the the impact of a
booster as dr wilinski said is really
important so we obviously want to
continue to drive that number higher and
higher the percent of americans who have
boosters but over to you dr fauci and
then over to you dr wolinski
well jeff you know i i'm really not sure
you're asking a good question it's
almost a
psychological sociological question why
were people who had
enough uh understanding of the risk to
go ahead and get
the primary series why we don't have
more
getting the booster i don't have a easy
explanation for that
that's one of the reasons why
we keep trying to put the data out
because as dr wolinski showed in her
slide
the data are really stunningly obvious
why a booster is really very important
you first need to get vaccinated before
you get boosted that's for sure but when
you look at the difference
of how booster for everything you ask it
to do
to reconstitute from an immunological
and from a clinical standpoint
the diminished protection that you get
not only with waning
naturally of immunity but also the
negative impact on some of the variants
that elude the immune response
fortunately for us
when you boost with the standard vaccine
which is against
the original viral sequence that you get
such a good response so the only thing
that we can do is to continue
to come out with the data and to make
sure the american public appreciates why
it is so important for optimal
protection to get boosted
and maybe i'll just add in there with
regard to where cases and
hospitalizations are i think we are all
cautiously optimistic as we're seeing
cases come down week over week down 36
percent over the last week
i do think we have to use an important
metric as a barometer which is how are
our hospitals doing and our
hospitalization rates are still quite
high and certainly um having hospital
capacity challenges in many parts of the
country still
so with that barometer um we've said
before omicron milder does not mean mild
and so we really do have to look to our
hospitalization rates and our death
rates to look to when is time to lift
some of these mitigation efforts we will
continue to re-evaluate and we know
people are anxious
next question please
go to genie bauman at bloomberg
hi thanks for taking my question um i
was hoping jeffy could be a little bit
more um when you said short order for
the availability of those kids vaccines
where you make something do you mean
like a week or a few days and then dr
fauci i was hoping you could talk a
little bit about the pandemic
preparedness um plan that naaid released
today and you know how the lessons from
covet helped drive some of those plans
and and what type of funding do you need
um to implement it
thank you yeah so uh on the um
vaccines for kids under five we're doing
all the preparation now
that we can do
to be ready so that it'll be available
at trusted locations uh as soon as
possible uh post i wanna emphasize again
fda and cdc recommendations
we cannot begin actually packing and
shipping
until the fda authorization and then
there's the cdc asip process which
generally takes place a matter of days
after the fda
so we're talking um you know a matter of
uh several days to a week or so
based on the five to 11 year experience
of from fda authorization
to when the first doses will start to be
shots and arms but we'll move as fast as
possible pending the decision of cdc
and fda and i think the preparation
we're doing now will enable us to do so
the second part of your question
yeah i'll i'll answer that jeff she was
asking about the pandemic preparedness
plan
you know very briefly jeanne it is
really uh founded on what we've been
talking about for some time now
which is the prototype pathogen approach
where you
get fundamental
information data and preparedness
on each of the multiple families that
are projected to be as a risk for
example
fortunately for us
we had been doing that with the
coronaviruses
when we got a lot of information from
sars co v1 and mayors and were already
involved in the preparation of both
platform technology and immunogen design
we plan to do that by selecting out
anywhere from 10 to 20 families of
viruses in which we can find
common denominators within the family
and do the immunological background
to do the development of phase one type
vaccine so that we could hit the ground
running
the second part of the program relates
to both the development and the
discovery of antiviral drugs those that
are already around
namely have been used for other purposes
that we might apply them to whatever of
the families that i mentioned a moment
ago
but the other is to use the replication
cycle
of the viruses similar to what we did
with hiv
and what we're doing with covet 19 to be
able to develop antivirals against the
whole family that's just kind of a
snapshot of the plan that the nih just
recently put out with regard to the
budget i mean obviously it's too early
to talk about that because we're in
negotiations right now for what our
budgetary needs are thank you next
question please
let's go to meg tourell at cnbc
thanks um one for dr crouching one for
dr wolenski um for dr fauci are you
expecting we'll see an efficacy update
with the data for kids under five i
think a lot of parents are
unsure about how optimistic they should
be feeling right now um when the last
update we got was that the immuno
bridging study didn't meet goals so are
you expecting to see that we'll actually
see this prevent cases of coved um and
then for dr walensky can you give us an
update on ba2 its prevalence and your
expectation for how it could affect sort
of the curve of this omicron wave
yeah meg thank you i mean obviously we
are anticipating that we will get a good
efficacy signal
for the use of vaccines in children
under five years old but right now as
you know the fda is looking at the data
very carefully and in their typical
fashion
they will be very careful in
scrutinizing the data and making a
recommendation of the decision based on
that data so i don't want to get ahead
of them but of course we're anticipating
we will get a vaccine efficacy signal
that would allow for the use of this
vaccine in children but let's wait for
the fda determination and ultimately the
cdc recommendation dr wolinski
yeah great um thank you meg for that
question so um our genomic surveillance
now is detecting ba2 i'm projecting
around one and a half percent in this
country of course that varies for
different parts of the country but
around one of one and a half percent
projection of the sequences that we're
seeing what we know about ba2 so far is
that it does have a modest transmission
advantage over ba1 however it's not
nearly the transmission advantage that
we've seen between omicron and delta in
terms of early studies we have not seen
any studies that suggest it's more
severe
nor have we seen studies that suggest
that it will evade our vaccines any more
so than omicron has already and in fact
that our vaccines will work just like it
has with omicron
um
so so in terms of how we anticipate this
will uh impact cases in many places
we've seen ba2 so far um cases have
continued to come down although at a
slower rate in some cases in some
countries like denmark um cases have
gone up associated with ba ii but that's
also in the context of relaxing
mitigation strategies mitigation
measures which is why we're currently
keeping those in place among the reasons
jackson and uh please
meg at the heart of your question i
think is something that many parents may
be wondering about which is what's
changed between december when pfizer uh
shared their news and and now and there
it's a big change that's happened which
is we experienced the omicron surge and
with many children in particular uh as
well as adults being
infected and ending up in the hospital
during the omicron surge it turns out
that has actually facilitated the
collection of more of important clinical
data additional clinical data that we
did not have
in december
whether that changes the risk benefit
profile is what the fda will be
assessing
but there has been developments since
december on the data front
next question please
jacqueline howard had cnn
thank you for taking my question um i
understand that earlier this week
governors who met with the president
expressed that they were seeking more
queer guidelines from the white house on
what the transition out of the pandemic
and into a greater state of normality
might look like
obviously i know we're not quite there
yet but my question is when might we see
such guidance and can you give us any
insight into
if and how those guidelines will be
prepared what metrics will be considered
and how will that guidance be
communicated to state leaders and to the
public thank you
well as you
can see from the discussion today right
now our
focus is on fighting omicron um while
cases are coming down as dr wolinski
pointed out there's still a high level
of hospitalization
largely driven
as the data shows by the unvaccinated at
the same time we are always you know
planning for
the future the most important thing that
we have now when
comparing to
a year ago
are the tools to protect people the
vaccines and and the effectiveness that
we've talked about particularly with
boosters that offer the highest highest
level of protection
a pediatric vaccine
on the horizon
and treatments including pills
that are highly effective against severe
disease and hospitalization so we are in
a much stronger position than a year ago
we have 210 million people fully
vaccinated including 75 3 out of 4 of
every adult
we had less than a percent
when the president took office a year
ago people vaccinated so from one
percent up to 75 percent of adults
98 99 of schools are open
that number was 46 when the president
took office we have free tests free mass
and booster shots widely available so
our progress
over the last year and the tools we now
have
certainly allow us
to get closer to a time
when covet doesn't disrupt our daily
lives but it's something we protect
against and treat
and as we make more progress against
omicron
uh we'll you know get closer to that
point
next question please
what is he
uh jeff's last point there uh
and maybe at the doctor's input as well
in terms of that pathway to that vision
of of a point where kobe 19 doesn't
alter americans daily lives you know for
many of the past couple of years it
feels a little bit like you know they're
they're charlie brown and football here
where it's you know get vaccinated and
nobody you can get a booster but even if
you're vaccinated you're boosted you
still need to wear your mask to protect
people who aren't vaccinated is there a
sense yet that you can offer the
american public based upon your studies
based on what you now know about
omnicron
no is this the last wave is there enough
that you can say
by a point certain
covet will not impact people's daily
lives anymore and and if not you know
why not what else do you need to know dr
fauci
well we have to be totally honest that
we don't know where we believe that we
are now going in the right direction
and the best case scenario as i and my
colleagues have often described
is that with the tools that we have
the vaccination the boosting the testing
the masking and all the other
mitigations that we know about
when you have a
level of
community protection which is the level
of immunity throughout the community
that we will reach a stage and i hope
that it's sooner rather than later
when as you have said this will not
dominate our lives in other words it
will be similar
to the assimilation
of this virus in the group of viruses
that we have learned
to live with without disruption
of our society you know their rsvs the
para influenzas the influenzas
where it's there it's present it hasn't
been eradicated it hasn't been
eliminated but it isn't at a level that
it essentially dominates what we do
and dramatically influences our lives we
believe we will get there we can't
guarantee that there will not be another
variant that challenges us
but the best that we can do with that
is to be prepared for it and that's why
we're doing all the things that we're
doing with regard to getting better
more um
the advanced vaccine
for example different platforms
different image and designs
development and discovery of new drugs
all of that
will be part of the armamentarium that
will ultimately even with the appearance
of additional variance will get us to
the point
where we will not be dominated by this
virus where we can return to a degree of
normality that we all crave for
please
all right time for a couple more
questions let's go to sheryl stohlberg
at the new york times
thanks for um taking this question it's
for jeff and for dr falchi
senators murray and burr have proposed a
legislation that would
create a task force to examine the
initial emergence of the coronavirus and
also assess the united states response
across both the trump and biden
administrations
it would be appointed
by congress not by the white house and
i'm wondering to jeff
is this something that the president
supports
and for dr fauci do you think it's
necessary to conduct an inquiry into the
origins of the virus
well cheryl thanks for the the question
let's start with you know we share the
senator's focus a lot of the bill
is about building stronger public health
systems and we
appreciate the bipartisan goals to
ensure
the country's better prepared
for outbreaks
in the future like covid
right now as we've been talking about
our you know focus is a hundred percent
on fighting omicron and covid and while
cases are coming down the
hospitalizations as we discussed are are
still quite high
um and across time uh we do look forward
to
engaging with congress and reviewing
lessons learned from this pandemic
so i think that right now our focus is
on omicron but we appreciate the the
work the senators have done and look
forward to working with them
dr fauci
yeah cheryl i think it's important to
look at every aspect of this outbreak
for lessons learned
that is not only what the origin of the
virus and the origin of the outbreak is
but many other things that we could
learn from in the future so that we can
prevent something like this happening or
respond better
if and when it does one of those is
understanding
what the origin of the virus is and it's
very important for example
studies were done with the first saw's
cov1
that we experienced in 2002 and 2003
and there was a mystery about how that
happened and then finally after a lot of
studies that actually took years
to finally show
that the origin was from a bat to an
intermediate host to a human very likely
in a wet market type situation
that was very important because that led
to things that unfortunately
were not followed namely a better
control and regulation
of the wild animal trade and the
interface between humans and animals
the other one was mares in which it was
shown finally that this was a bat
reservoir that very likely infected
camels and camels to human
that also provides public health
guidelines for the interaction of an
animal human interface so it would be
obviously important to be able to
determine
how this went from what was very likely
an animal reservoir given the similarity
with bad viruses how that happened to go
into humans to lead to this outbreak
understanding that
will help us to prepare
for any future outbreak as well as
prepare for a response so i'm definitely
in favor of that
kevin
last question let's go to peter sullivan
to hell
hi thanks um there's a group of
democrats in congress have called for
17 billion dollars in the next
appropriations package for global
vaccinations and other aspects of the
global response i'm wondering if the
white house supports that and are you
planning to you know ask congress for
that in the next package thanks
so we have um what we need in this
current fight against omicron and we've
done a lot to prepare for what's ahead
we have boosters for all americans we've
secured 20 million
doses of the highly effective
pfizer pill we've expanded supplies
and stockpiles of ppe
including masks and gloves
so while we have
enough money enough funding
for the current immediate needs we need
to continue as we've talked about to
stay ahead of the virus
and we are looking at a future where we
will likely need funding for treatments
and pills
we'll need funding to
continue to expand testing and to
continue to lead the effort as we've
done with 1.2 billion doses donated to
the world but to continue to lead that
effort to vaccinate the
world so we will be
working with congress as needed to make
sure we have the funding to continue to
fight this virus
i want to thank everybody for the
questions and look forward to the next
briefing thank you
the threat from the chinese communist
party it is a subterfuge intended to
conceal what this legislation is
actually about a repackaged build back
better and the debt the democrats back
up plan to push their green new deal
agenda it's 350 billion dollars in
deficit spending to pay off the climate
activists and the labor unions that run
the democrat party it sends 10 billion
dollars of taxpayer funds to a climate
slush fund at the u n that subsidizes
solar projects in china that use uyghur
slave labor the bill implements a supply
chain resiliency program that gives
preferential treatment to labor unions a
scheme designed more to maintain
resiliency for democratic party
fundraising than resiliency of our
supply chains the bill references coral
reefs more times than china and climate
change twice as much as national
security the bill bans overfishing and
the sale of shark fins from the pacific
but it doesn't put more virginia class
subs in the pacific it doesn't put more
ford class aircraft carriers in the
pacific it does nothing to hold the ccp
accountable for the origins of covet at
the wuhan institute of virology by
trying to copy china's big government
central planning industrial policy the
bill would actually make the united
states less not more competitive we
cannot out compete china by trying to
become more like china
but most troubling of all and what
underscores that this bill is not a
serious effort to confront the very real
economic and security challenges posed
by the people's republic of china is the
fact that this bill completely
disregards the work of the china task
force as well as the work of this the
bipartisan u.s china economic and
security review commission if this bill
were serious it would take into account
these recommendations it does neither of
those things this was a very serious
effort that this bill completely
disregards
exhibit a of how unserious the bill is
when it comes to confronting china it
does nothing to confront the unfettered
access of chinese
thank you 30 seconds
exhibit is recognized for additional one
minute thank you mr speaker and thank
thank the gentleman exhibit a of how
unserious this bill is when it comes to
confronting china is how it does nothing
to address the key challenge facing us
from china and that is the unfettered
access that the chinese communist party
military and surveillance companies now
have to american capital markets if we
really wanted to confront the threat
from china we would protect american
investors from unwittingly financing and
fueling
the rise of china this bill does nothing
to address that right now american
investors are unwittingly fueling the
civil military fusion of the chinese
communist party the house should pass a
real bill a bill recommended by this
report the chinese military and
surveillance company sanctions act that
would actually address
chinese access to american capital
markets today mr speaker i urge my
colleagues to reject this subterfuge
reject this distraction
this bill that they say confronts china
but does nothing of the sort that
actually assists and enables the rise of
china let's formulate a real strategy
that will position us to take on the
military economic and technological
threat of the chinese communist party
and i yield back the gentleman from
florida reserves general lady from texas
is recognized
thank you mr speaker i yield one minute
to the generator from california me too
the gentlelady from california is
recognized for one minute i rise today
in strong support of the america
competes act which will make historic
investments in america and ensure we we
remain a global leader in science and
technology
from climate change to cyber security
many of the greatest challenges facing
our country can only be met through
research and innovation that will
develop new products and create new jobs
but in order to rise to this moment we
need to turbo charge america's
scientific sector and that is what this
bill would do by investing 52 billion
dollars for semiconductor production
here at home an investment that will
improve the supply chain for almost
every product in our lives and it
modernizes the national science
foundation to advance america's
scientific leadership by supporting
institutions like caltech based in my
district which is one of nsf's most
trusted partners
i want to thank my colleagues today who
have modeled responsibility in debating
this bill by focusing on what we gain
and not who we should fear
thank you and i yield back
the gentlelady from texas reserves the
gentleman from florida is recognized mr
speaker i yield one minute to the
gentleman from illinois mr lahood
two minutes
the gentleman from illinois is
recognized for two minutes
thank you mr speaker and i want to thank
the gentleman for yielding the time i
rise today in opposition of the
so-called competes act
instead of following the productive
bipartisan efforts initiated in the
senate house democrats have chosen the
go at it alone approach that fails to
meet the urgent needs to strengthen u.s
competitiveness and protect our national
security as it relates to china
on the ways and means committee i've
worked across the aisle on china policy
with my democrat colleagues including
trade priorities to bring manufacturing
back to the united states to hold china
to their trade commitments and to
prioritize digital trade agreements with
like-minded allies to combat china's
abusive digital standards yet here we
are today democrats are pushing partisan
legislation stocked with more d.c
control over our economy that fails to
address the critical trade initiatives
to put american workers and businesses
first and to counter the market
distorting and dangerous economic
practices of china as a member of the
intelligence committee and the china
task force and the co-chair of the
bipartisan u.s china working group i
understand the unique and urgent action
required to strengthen american
competitiveness and combat growing
challenges from china it's disappointing
that house democrats are again ignoring
this opportunity to work together with
republicans as they did in the senate
republicans and democrats together to
put forth a common sense bill where is
that bill it's not here
we need to address the real challenges
presented by china
and instead we are cynically pushing
forward unrelated liberal agenda items
vote no i yield back
the gentleman from florida reserves the
gentlelady from texas is recognized
thank you mr speaker yeah two minutes to
the general lady from oregon miss
bonamici
the gentle lady from oregon is
recognized for two minutes thank you mr
speaker i rise in strong support of the
america competes act our country is home
to some of the most cutting-edge
research innovative discoveries and
unparalleled national laboratories in
the world unfortunately in some ways
we've fallen behind competitors during
the past several decades but with this
legislation we will strengthen our
scientific enterprise bolster research
and development grow our domestic
semiconductor manufacturing base and
make sure critical supply chains are
based in the us this legislation
includes a provision similar to my
regional clean energy innovation act to
help cutting-edge technologies achieve
commercialization by leveraging regional
clean energy capabilities and markets as
co-chair of the house apprenticeship
caucus i'm thrilled that competes
includes not only the national
apprenticeship act but also my partners
act which will promote workforce
training and help more people access
good paying jobs i'm very grateful to
chair johnson for her leadership on this
bill and to chair mcgovern for making in
order six of my amendments if
incorporated they will help address
climate change improve workforce
development and enhance stem education
in particular the blue carbon for our
planet act blue globe act and coast
research act will strengthen coastal
acidification research and monitoring
expand efforts to map and conserve blue
carbon ecosystems and enhance ocean data
collection and my bipartisan builds act
which provides grants for infrastructure
industry partnerships will play a
pivotal role in helping workers get the
skills they need to fill the jobs
created by the bipartisan infrastructure
law and my amendment with mr langevin to
enhance nf nsf's mathematics and science
education partnership program will
support innovative research and provide
professional development
by for educators on how to boost
creativity in stem by integrating the
arts the competes act will reinvigorate
america's research enterprise and
restore its competitive edge i strongly
urge my colleagues to support this
important bill thank you mr chairman
again i thank chairwoman johnson and i
yield back the balance of my time
the gentlelady from texas reserves the
gentleman from florida is recognized
mr speaker i yield two minutes to the
gentleman from ohio mr shabbat
the gentleman from ohio is recognized
for two minutes thank you mr speaker and
i thank the gentleman for yielding as
ranking member of the asia pacific
subcommittee which has jurisdiction over
china i rise today in strong opposition
to the america competes act which should
really be called the america concedes
act
after decades of inaction it's high time
we reevaluate our basic approach towards
engagement with china on every front the
chinese communist party is aggressively
challenging the free world and the
premise that open societies and free
markets in the rule of law logically
result in a prosperous and equitable
civilization
the ccp's ambitions have thrust us into
a new cold war that we did not start and
we do not want but which we must win
because if we fail the chinese communist
party will replace the post-world war ii
order with one that revolves around
beijing
this moment calls for bold policies to
ensure that we win this struggle
on this score today's legislation is
woefully deficient it's stuffed full of
irrelevant provisions
the foreign affairs committee section of
the bill is a prime example it fails to
take advantage of serious tools like
export controls and security assistance
and instead spends twice as much money
on climate policy as it does
on china-related matters
democratic leadership has refused to
even allow debate on ranking member
mccall's serious amendment or in a
package that i offered that includes 13
tough relevant proposals crafted by
subcommittee republicans
we must take the chinese communist
party's threat
seriously
if we don't
we're going to see
china continuing to eat our lunch and
steal our jobs this democratic effort
was an opportunity for bipartisanship
and actually doing something that
mattered
they blew it
let's face it and that's most
unfortunately and therefore i have to
encourage my colleagues to oppose their
misguided legislation today i yield back
the gentleman from florida reserves
gentlelady from texas is recognized
mr speaker i yield one minute to the
general lady from michigan miss lawrence
the gentlelady from michigan is
recognized for one minute
i rise today in strong support of the
completes act i'm proud to represent the
big three automotive states
and a district where gm is headquartered
i know how important it is to fix our
supply chain
semiconductors
power our economy everything from
smartphones to computers to cars we have
to start making them here in america
this legislation will make sure that
while increasing
american
innovation manufacturing
and r d and i'm proud to offer two
amendments to ensure that our efforts in
the completes act is centered around
equality so that all americans will
benefit from the significant r d
investment of our critical goods
while creating good jobs let's get this
done so we can ensure
that our economy is secure and
strengthen our global competitiveness i
yield back
the gentle lady from texas reserves the
gentleman from florida is recognized mr
speaker i yield five minutes to the
gentleman from arkansas the republican
leader of the national resources
committee mr westerman
the gentleman from arkansas is
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr speaker today i think about
when my four children were young they're
stair-stepped two years apart they used
to have
competitions in the backyard they would
race from the patio to the elm tree and
back and i would stagger the starting
time let the youngest one go first then
the next the youngest and so on and by
the time they touched the tree and came
back it turned into a real competition
a photo finish a lot of times we've all
competed in games whose outcome has
little significance in life but mr
speaker we're not facing an
insignificant competition competition in
our future
we are in a race of ideologies the
states are as high as they can be we are
literally in a struggle for the future
of western civilization of democracy of
representative government of human
rights and freedom
mr speaker this isn't a matter of
competing it's a must-win scenario and
quite frankly i'm aghast that this
majority thinks that we only need to
compete
losing is not an option our attitude
must be to win
if we lose humanity loses i believe
freedom loving republicans democrats
independents and people all across the
world want america to win
i'm disappointed that the speaker and
this majority have once again dropped a
massive bill that could and should be
bipartisan but instead is a cloak for
failed build back better policies that
lie dead in the senate
mr speaker
you and i have a rendezvous with destiny
we will preserve for our children this
the last best hope of man on earth or we
will sentence them to take the first
step into a thousand years of darkness
if we fail
at least let our children and our
children's children say of us we
justified our brief moment here
we did all that could be done
those familiar words were from ronald
reagan in the 1960s but they've never
been more true than today how serious
are the issues that we face
take a look at these charts from the
economist this first one is in 2000 the
blue is the u.s and it's trading
partners the red is china and it's
trading partners look what's happened in
a short 20-year span as we look at this
same map from 2022
we see massive increase in red on this
map and a massive decrease of blue on
this map
what do provisions in this bill from the
blue new deal have to do with us winning
against china it does the exact opposite
by killing american jobs restoring coral
reefs off our coast is a commendable
goal but what does spending 292 million
dollars on coral reef restoration have
to do with us winning against china this
bill gives supreme unilateral authority
to the u.s fish and wildlife service to
determine what species can be imported
into the u.s
this so-called plot list mandated in the
bill is virtually impossible to
implement and will effectively shut down
aquaculture and similar industries who
need trade to conduct business the
weaponization of the lacey act will only
empower bureaucrats and ignores the
current state-based approach on species
imports it's legislative laziness since
there have been no hearings or even an
introduced bill on this topic
what in the world does that have to do
with winning against china the bill
requires biased studies and new
heavy-handed regulations designed to
kill american mineral development mr
speaker how can this majority propose
this bill while the democratic
administration continues to illustrate
incompetency by killing american energy
and jobs and even pulling mining leases
in minnesota
that could create jobs and supply
resources
for the very policies on electrification
the administration supports this only
shifts wealth and jobs to china how does
that help us win
it reminds me of my kids races where the
majority is trying to handicap america
and give china a head start
what we should be to do
should be doing to have a winning
strategy we should be working together
on this on real issues to assure that
america wins we should be strengthening
diplomacy and trade with our allies and
create a solid western hemisphere
alliance to ensure that america wins we
should be developing our resources and
jobs to help america win we should be
part of the solution and not the problem
americans and freedom will win if we let
them
as i close i want to remind you of a
fable by esop the eagle and the arrow
the eagle was struck by an arrow and as
you lie on the ground he looked back at
it
and he said alas
i have been wounded by an arrow
that was
feathered with my own plume
mr speaker we cannot afford to put more
plumes on china's arrows i oppose this
bill and i yield back
the gentleman from florida reserves the
gentlelady from texas is recognized
thank you mr speaker i yield three
minutes to a distinguished gentleman
from massachusetts mr neal
the gentleman from massachusetts is
recognized for three minutes
strong support of the american competes
act this legislation will transport our
nation to the future it will strengthen
supply chains advanced manufacturing and
create millions of jobs ways and means
members assertively made their
contributions to this package
including a strong provision for trade
adjustment assistance and to the
previous speaker i know he was sincere
in what he said
there will be a final package it'll be
bicameral in nature bipartisan in nature
it's just too important to get done the
rhythms of legislative life will dictate
that outcome this is a full effort of
the house and to say that there are no
provisions in here that republicans will
favor is simply untrue the trade
subcommittee chairman earl blumenauer
has been a very important leader in
developing this legislation and along
with our colleague tim ryan who has not
stopped telling me of just how important
this is to ohio to fund the nation's
newest semiconductor factory this is a
good bold proposal and i am going to
remain standing madam speaker so that i
might yield the balance of my time to
the trade subcommittee chair mr
blumenauer
a careful examination of this bill shows
many bipartisan proposals one area of
bipartisan agreement is that for too
long america has been too weak in its
engagement with china the chinese
government is strengthening its economic
power while doubling down on religious
persecution and forced labor those
practices undercut the competitiveness
of american workers in business congress
must stop step up and confront china
head on our trade title does just that
those damaged by trade whether workers
business or farmers will benefit from a
dramatically improved trade adjustment
assistance program which expired in june
and completely phases out in july our
provisions modernizing and reauthorizing
gsp and mtb will improve american
competitiveness and labor standards
around the globe and we get tough on
china by closing the de minimis loophole
that allows 800 per day per person
for products undoubtedly including
forced labor intellectual property theft
and illegal goods china doesn't give us
reciprocity on de minimis their
threshold is less than eight dollars
they're not about to subject their
companies to duty-free unregulated
american competition allowing items like
air conditioners microwaves and
suitcases under mtv doesn't help
american manufacturing it undercuts it
and directly undermines congress's goal
of rebuilding domestic capacity our
changes restore the programs back to
their original attempt supporting
american workers and domestic
manufacturing not undercutting american
suppliers at its simplest this
legislation meets workers needs and
bolsters americans capacity to compete
if you want to support the american
worker
and get tough on china you have a chance
to do so with this bill i urge everyone
to vote in the affirmative
thank you
gentlewoman of florida reserves the
gentlemen from florida is recognized
madam speaker are you one minute to the
gentleman from pennsylvania mr mouser
the gentleman is recognized thank you
madam speaker i thank my good friend
colleague
the gentleman from florida
madam speaker we have far too many
domestic and international crises facing
us right now to name them here from the
southern border to ukraine to
afghanistan to the crime in philadelphia
streets to soaring gasoline prices
supply chain bottlenecks we have an
opportunity here to make the u.s economy
more competitive we can do that with the
right bill particularly against our
number one competitor and often
adversary china
rather than lower the costs for american
and large
large and small businesses madam speaker
and creating a more competitive business
environment this so-called america
competes act places burdens
on the american economy in the form of
debt
and regulations is filled with special
interest subsidies nobody can deny that
and has a whopping
325 billion dollar price tag to go along
with our our escalating deficit in debt
meanwhile the only part of the 325
billion that i agree with and i believe
my constituents agree with would be the
chips usa act and some of the
gentleman's time
can i
yield 30 seconds yield 30 seconds madam
speaker
uh this bill really is a plethora of new
government programs which will uh not
advance the u.s economy madam speaker
this bill will likely get the vote of
china but would not get the vote of
american small business the ccp is very
serious about economic growth with
little regard for how to get there we
have better wake up or we will be
responsible for letting them i yield
back thank you
gentlewoman of texas is recognized
madam speaker how much time we have
remaining
33 minutes
thank you very much i yield one minute
to the gentlelady from pennsylvania miss
wow
thank you madam speaker i am proud to
rise in support of the competes act this
legislation incorporates two bills that
my office introduced the supply chain
security and resilience act and the
regional innovation act at a time when
the need to finally secure our supply
chains and rebuild a made in america
economy could not be clearer my
provisions of the bill from the supply
chain security and resilience act will
put us on the path to doing just that by
creating a new office within the
commerce department to promote u.s
leadership of critical industries and
supply chains that are essential to our
national and economic security we will
join businesses and government and
common national effort the regional
innovation act would establish a
regional technology and innovation hub
program at the department of commerce to
support regional economic development
and innovation hubs nationwide
we can ensure that workers and
businesses from all corners of our
country not just the coasts benefit from
investment my community pennsylvania's
greater lehigh valley is full of workers
and businesses who have the vision the
talent and the grit to reach global
economic heights they deserve the
exposure to get their products to market
our country has extraordinary promise
gentlemen's has expired bill thank you
madam speaker i yield back gentleman
from texas are from florida is
recognized
madam speaker i yield one minute to the
gentleman from north carolina mr murphy
gentleman is recognized madam speaker
this so-called competition bill proves
just how feckless democrats are about
confronting our biggest adversary the
chinese communist party
why is this president so afraid to call
out china they are our greatest
generational threat to democracy human
rights and the american way of life
china will stop at nothing
until they have world domination
the confronting communist china should
be a clear bipartisan priority as
secretary pompeo recently said the
chinese have infiltrated our schools
businesses and politics and will stop at
nothing until they have world domination
we should be coming together on our
strong and a strong consensus framework
that holds china accountable and
strengthens our national security
instead speaker pelosi offers more
poison pills that will be dead on the
rival in the senate let us stop the
nonsensical leftist progressive
messaging and be serious about our jobs
democrats have steamrolled congress with
yet and another multi-billion dollar
package thousands of pages long without
proper analysis our nation now hits a 30
trillion dollar debt mark this week i
refuse to support another package that
sends hard-earned taxpayer dollars to
the chinese communist party please i
urge my colleagues to vote no on the
american seeds america concedes to china
act
gentlewoman
from texas is recognized ma'am speaker i
yield one minute to the gentleman from
michigan mr kielde gentleman is
recognized
thank you madam speaker i rise in
support of the american america competes
act with this legislation we have an
opportunity to strengthen domestic
supply chains to invest in american
manufacturing into lower costs for
families for small businesses for
seniors this pandemic has exposed deep
weaknesses in our supply chains that
have increasingly relied on foreign
manufacturing instead of making goods
right here in america with american
workers this bill will help fix our
broken supply chains
so that we can build more critical
components here in america not overseas
in china where the government exploits
its own people for michigan auto workers
this includes addressing the
semiconductor chip shortage which has
shuttered auto plants and forced
thousands of auto workers to temporarily
be laid off this bill will invest
billions to bring chip manufacturing
back to the united states and also this
legislation includes
my legislation
to create a new trade adjustment
assistance for communities program that
will help many older industrial
communities that have been negatively
impacted by trade communities like flint
and saginaw bay city taa for communities
will address the needs and the time has
expired local economic development
strategies i urge my colleagues to
support this legislation yield back
gentleman from florida's record madam
speaker i yield one one minute to the
gentlewoman from georgia miss green
gentlewoman is recognized thank you
madam speaker i rise in opposition to
another bill that puts china first at
america last
instead of focusing on a bill that's
almost 3 000 pages worth
325 estimated
bill billion in spending estimated
that doesn't really help america it's
going to give out eight billion dollars
to the u.n climate fund and mentions
coral reefs 383 times what congress
should be doing is working on a budget
that will fund our government since
we're running out of money in just a few
weeks what congress should be doing is
doing something about the fentanyl
that's coming from china that's killing
young people it is now the number one
cause of death in americans from 18 to
45 not covet 19. what congress should be
doing is is funding a wall building a
wall protecting our border and deporting
illegal aliens who are stealing american
jobs that's what we should be doing to
help the american worker but instead
we're debating a bill that's going to
fund climate change the green new deal
and help the coral reefs this isn't what
americans care about we all should be
voting no and doing a better job
gentlewoman of texas is recognized
madam speaker
i request one minute
of the final lady from
new mexico
miss ferdinand
the gentlewoman is recognized
madam speaker would the america competes
act we will invent it in america we will
build it in america and we will create
american jobs importantly competes gives
us the opportunity to discover develop
and make what we need everywhere in
america
that's why i introduced and urged my
colleagues to support four amendments
that could expand jobs to rural
latin latino native american and
minority communities the workers that
produce what america needs must look
like america the competes act could
invest billions of dollars to build
chips and conduct research in new mexico
and other communities facing economic
despair with my amendments this bill can
create jobs for that beautifully diverse
workforce that powered our nation as we
transition to clean energy energy
workers deserve economic opportunity in
a changing world let's ensure we have
the innovation training and jobs for
american workers everywhere as we power
a prosperous
future thank you madam speaker i yield
back
gentlemen of florida is recognized
uh
february sir excuse me there we are
madam speaker are you one one minute to
the gentlewoman from missouri miss
hartzler
the gentleman is recognized
thank you
i rise in opposition to the so-called
america competes act
let's put let's be clear
china is one of the largest national
security threats our nation faces
addressing this threat will require a
whole of nation approach with policies
to enable the united states to not only
compete but beat china this legislation
fails to achieve that goal unfortunately
the democrats have once again
rushed through a massive package riddled
with partisan and unvetted policies that
enriches china rather than constraining
them amazingly the democrats block
consideration of all my common sense
amendments which would have prevented
known chinese spies from entering our
nation
stopped ccp officials from taking
advantage of our higher education system
and sanctioned those responsible for
forced abortions and for sterilizations
of uyghur women
if democrats were serious about
protecting america they should have
welcomed these common sense measures
this legislation fails to address the
threat of china i urge my colleagues to
oppose this legislation and instead work
on legislation that will actually
empower the united states to beat china
i yield back the gentlewoman from texas
is recognized
thank you madam speaker i yield one
minute to the gentleman from north
carolina mr price gentleman is
recognized
madam chair i rise in strong support of
the american competes act in particular
the inclusion of legislation to
reauthorize title vi of the higher
education act
sponsored by myself and representative
young of alaska
this will
help our nation develop a strong
foundation in international education
research and world language studies
especially in languages that holds
essential strategic interests the back
partisan bicameral bill will increase
and expand these programs incorporating
some 200 languages and also build
international capacity at minority
serving institutions
in addition the america competes act
enhances the advanced technological
education program that the national
science foundation
doubling the authorization for a program
that i helped initiate which strengthens
high-tech worker training through
community and technical colleges it
incentivizes critical partnerships
between
businesses and
schools to meet local workforce needs
madam chair i urge adoption of the
america competes act to better equip our
citizens to succeed in an inner
increasingly interconnected world thank
you
the gentleman from florida is recognized
madam speaker i yield one minute to the
gentleman from texas mr arrington
i think the gentleman from florida madam
speaker unfortunately and sadly enough
this is a
repeat of of the political ruse where
you wrap a flag and
give a great name to legislation the
reality is
has very little to do with the threats
that china poses to the united states
and the world there's plenty of common
ground we could find
to work on that
a big challenge a huge threat but
instead
this is a misleading piece of
legislation it is another legislative
wagon loaded with the same tired old
progressive policies union giveaways
green energy uh subsidies and unhinged
in my opinion social uh policies and
experimentation like training our armed
forces not to to fight and win wars but
to combat climate change and
naming a chief diversity officer that
should make us safer uh all sleep better
at night with respect to china listen
the democrat party madam chair has been
hijacked by the left
and they're willing to sacrifice
america's prosperity our security and
our global leadership on
climate apocalypse now i don't get it
thank you for the time and i yield back
the gentlewoman from texas is recognized
thank you mr speaker i yield one minute
to the gentle
lady from alabama miss sewell
the gentlewoman is recognized madam
speaker i rise today in support
strong support of the america competes
act i'm especially proud that my
legislation h.r 6121
the leveling the playing field act 2.0
was included in this bill this
bipartisan legislation sponsored by
myself and my republican colleague uh
bill
johnson will monit will modernize our
outdated trade remedy laws to push back
against many of china's most aggressive
uh anti-free market practices for years
a number of american industries have
faced repeated dumping and subsidized
imports to the u.s market
in 2000
china produced about 18 percent of the
world's steel today it produces roughly
50 percent this over capacity has
undermined u.s steel manufacturing and
has put our steel workers and steel
manufacturers like those in my district
u.s steel and new core at a big
disadvantage
at the end of the day
this bill will promote global
competitiveness and when
america competes fairly american workers
win and america businesses win thank you
i yield back gentleman from florida is
recognized madam speaker i yield one
minute to the gentleman from wisconsin
mr tiffany
the gentleman's recognized thank you
madam speaker lots of rhetoric today
about creating american jobs and having
american businesses thrive let's read
something that was slipped into this
bill a prohibition no person may possess
acquire receive transport offer for sale
sell or purchase any american mink
what a sneak attack on people that
create jobs and create goods for america
these people are good stewards good
stewards of the land and they are also
terrific at animal husbandry
and this is a sneak attack on them
trying to drive them out of business
when there's one question here when is
the hostility to the producers of
america the people that grow our food
clothe our people
and produce our energy going to end by
the other side of the aisle i yield back
the gentlewoman from texas is recognized
thank you madam speaker i yield one
minute to the gentleman from michigan
dental native from michigan miss dingle
the gentlewoman is recognized thank you
madam speaker and thank you madam
chairman i rise today in strong support
of h.r 54
45-21 the america competes act we stand
at a defining moment for the future of
american manufacturing and our global
competitiveness if we fail to act we put
both our economic security and our
national security at risk
this bold comprehensive package which
includes several of my bipartisan bills
will create good-paying american jobs
through investments to boost american
manufacturing bring our supply chain
home and keep america at the forefront
of innovation and technology the bill
includes 52 billion dollars in funding
including 2 billion for legacy
automotive chips to address the
semi-conductor chip shortages which have
crippled the auto industry shut down
plants in my district and invest in
domestic production of critical
medicines and ppe then meaningfully
addresses rising prices for everyday
goods and in michigan and across the
nation too many americans have been
impacted and are counting on us fixing
this by passing the america competes act
we will solidify our future leadership
around the globe and strengthen our
workforce here at home i urge all of my
colleagues to support this bill and
yield back
the gentleman from florida is recognized
madam speaker i yield one minute to the
gentlewoman from west virginia miss
miller the gentleman is recognized thank
you madam speaker president biden's
trade moratorium undermines u.s
leadership and hands all adversaries a
dangerous opportunity to get ahead
china is seizing this moment to advance
in the indo-pacific this is why i joined
with my colleague darren lahood to
introduce the u.s trade leadership in
the indo-pacific and china act
our bill will require president biden to
act and report on a trade strategy in
the indo-pacific and with china
once again
democrats didn't allow any bipartisan
input in their legislation
there has been zero guidance by
president biden on a trade plan with
china
instead we continue on a useless wait
and see approach
the competition between the us and china
demands strong leadership
democrats must wake up to this reality
and take decisive action
i urge my colleagues to support our bill
and to ensure america's lasting trade
leadership
the gentlewoman of texas is recognized
thank you madam speaker i yield three
minutes to the gentleman from new york
the chair of the foreign affairs
committee mr meeks the gentleman is
recognized
thank you madam speaker
i rise today in strong support of this
bill
we find ourselves in a strategic
competition
with an increasingly assertive people's
republic of china
the prc is trying to manipulate and
alter the economic political and
security underpinnings of the
american-led rules-based international
order an order that has broken decades
of peace
prosperity stability
for many
and it has grown in as it has grown in
wealth and power
we've seen the prc bend international
rules and laws to meet its interests
bully nations over maritime and water
border disputes and grow more closed and
authoritarian at home
today the prc is systemically leveraging
its growing military
economic and technological health
heft to complete
with us
globally
and that's happening whether we like it
or not
so we must record with the stark new
reality
by positioning america to win this
competition
and h.r
4521
the american competes act does just that
it powers the engine of the american
economy through investments in science
innovation
and technology
and it raises the flag of american
diplomacy and leadership to reassure the
world that america is indeed back at the
table
and ready to counter
china's efforts to manipulate the
international system and strengthen our
allies and partnerships
centering on the centering on diplomacy
in bolstering america's global
leadership and engagement are the themes
of my bill the eagle act which serves as
the foreign affairs division of american
competes the eagle act bolsters our
diplomacy bilaterally at regional
organizations and through groupings like
the quad to ensure that we bring our
partners and allies with us to prevent
the prc from undermining global rules it
demonstrates that the america that
america is capable and willing to tackle
the world's biggest problems and
marshall a response to shared challenges
like the current pandemic
and it ensures that the united states
will lead with its values and stand up
for international law and human rights
in many respects this legislation goes
further than the senate's competition
bill in terms of responding to the prc's
human rights abuses in addition to
sanctions related to the genocide at
xinjiang the eagle act contains refugee
protections for the uyghurs and han
congress and also calls for a special
envoy for xinjiang
i can say with absolute confidence
that when it comes to standing up for
our values america competes is bold and
principled
and with the gentleman's time is expired
this historic bill and urged my fellow
colleagues to do just the same the
gentleman from florida is recognized
madam speaker ask unanimous consent that
the gentleman from texas be allowed to
control the remaining time
someone from texas is recognized
madam speaker i'd like to yield two
minutes to the general gentleman from
utah mr moore the gentleman's recognized
thank you mr speaker i rise today in
opposition to h.r 4521
i i won't let my constituents be fooled
by
by an attempt here to recycle priorities
from president biden's failed
buildback better plan
while this bill plays a role in
formalizing a necessary discussion and
again there you'll you'll hear from my
comments that there is large bipartisan
support on what we need to do here um to
to to address the effects of a great
power competition on the american
economy it this is a superficial
partisan effort that will not properly
confront china and will only make
inflation work for american families
this pandemic dashed any illusion that
the chinese communist party can be can
be a trusted party a partner for
american business or will or they will
take any accountability when their
recklessness results in devastating
supply chain disruptions
enhancement to domestic manufacturing
that support american workers and
increase global competitiveness are long
overdue but sadly they will continue to
go unaddressed by this bill
because simply these this this
legislation does not require these
organizations to re-examine their
relationship with the ccp
and it's it's an addition in addition
it's it's it's another attempt to create
a big large piece of legislation where
you can add in a whole bunch of climate
change priorities and the american
people and as i talk to my constituents
they want us to address the issue at
hand not just lump a bunch of things in
together and again that's what we're
doing here by making it a china bill
there is an appetite and desire among
many of my colleagues to send a clear
message to the communist party in
beijing my constituents want a china
bill that confronts intellectual
property theft the genocide of religious
minorities ccp influence in civil
society the antagonism of our allies and
a bill that finally holds the ccp
accountable for their covering up of
covet 19. despite the grave threat our
nation faces from the ccp
american ascendancy can be maintained
only if we remain the preferred partner
across the world and the primary
destination for innovators and job
creators congress can and must do better
let's get back to work and i yield back
the gentlewoman from texas is recognized
thank you madam speaker i yield one
minute to the
gentleman from illinois mr caston
thank you madam speaker i rise today in
support of the competes act and i am
particularly proud of the house science
legislation in this bill designed to
ensure that the department of
energy office of science the national
science foundation and nist are well
equipped to succeed in the 21st century
it also invests in a stem workforce for
the future to ensure we have the talents
to bring all these semiconductor climate
manufacturing jobs back home where they
belong and if i could share a personal
story about 13 years ago i was building
a treehouse in my backyard
and as i was starting this six-year-old
neighborhood kid shows up behind me with
a cute little hard hat and a tool belt
and said i'm here to help and
my 2009 summer intern as it were is now
a sophomore at the university of
illinois studying nuclear engineering
his opportunity was made possible in
part by investments that were made
decades ago in nuclear technology and a
test reactor on that university of
illinois campus
that reactor is now at the end of life
it's been shut down and there are a few
other states that have those kinds of
opportunities that's why i look forward
to the consideration of my national
nuclear university research
infrastructure reinvestment act and
competes with congressman foster
congressman gonzalez and congressman
meyer it'll enhance the research
capabilities of nuclear science and
engineering programs meet the workforce
needs of the us nuclear industry and
accelerate the deployment of advanced
nuclear technologies in illinois and
across the country i hope my colleagues
will join me in supporting this bill as
we develop new generation advanced
nuclear energy at our nation the
gentleman's time has expired the
gentleman from texas is recognized
uh yes ma'am madam speaker i yield two
minutes at this time to the gentlewoman
from florida mrs caymac
gentlewoman is recognized
thank you madam speaker thank you to my
colleague from the great state of texas
i rise in strong opposition to this bill
which would be more appropriately named
the america concedes act heck we could
go so far as to say that this is the
american corruption act this bill has
nothing to do with countering china or
holding them accountable it's 2 900
pages 2 900 pages have any of my
colleagues supporting this bill actually
read the bill
i would venture no i would say no they
probably haven't because if they had
they would know what was in it and they
would recognize that it's selling us out
to china
i however have read this bill i have
spent the last couple days pouring
through the language and have found
egregious provision after egregious
provision and quite frankly it's
infuriating just one example is the fact
under section 61008
coveted pandemic measures could be
extended until december 31st 2025. what
better way to make americans dependent
on china for critical supplies like ppe
than to mandate that we get it from them
and make sure that covet provisions stay
in place another example is the 8
billion with a b authorization for the
green climate fund which was conceived
as a tool for incentivizing developing
countries to participate in the paris
climate agreement
in practice this un fund has done
nothing more but distort global energy
markets and even encourages corruption i
have an amendment to this bill that
would strike the funding and i urge my
colleagues to support that amendment
however we know that this is more about
politics than it is about good policy so
i'm not particularly optimistic however
i still would encourage my colleagues to
support that amendment
madam speaker this bill is misguided we
should stand as americans and counter
china and its rise support true american
innovation
i encourage my colleagues
to oppose this bill it is dangerous and
misguided
with that i yield back the gentlewoman
from texas is recognized thank you madam
speaker i yield one minute to the gentle
lady from georgia mrs baldwin
the gentlewoman is recognized
thank you madam chairwoman i rise in
strong support of the america competes
act a bill that would bolster american
leadership in critical economic sectors
for decades to come in addition to
necessary provisions to spur american
production of semiconductors the america
competes act would take action to
address supply chain disruptions and
shortages
my bill the supply chain act is included
in this package and will ensure the
newly created office of supply chain
resiliency and crisis response at the
department of commerce has the tools it
needs to map and monitor critical supply
chains as well as prepare for and
respond to supply chain shocks and
disruptions
i have heard from families and small
businesses and manufacturers in
georgia's 7th district of the challenges
presented by supply chain disruptions
especially amidst the pandemic this
package of supply chain resiliency
measures will help us to identify and
mitigate these disruptions moving
forward
in closing i would like to commend my
colleagues for their hard work in
assembling this critical legislation i
urge my colleagues on both sides of the
aisle to support the america competes
act and i yield back
texas is recognized
madam speaker
i stand in strong opposition
to what should be called the concedes
act
once again we're voting on a bill that
was forced through this chamber in a
partisan fashion and one that lacks
the policies needed to bolster our
competitiveness and combat the threats
from our foreign adversaries
the hard work and the bipartisan
collaboration of the space science and
technology committee has once again been
obliterated so that the left can pass
partisan policies
once again
in a sincere and goodwill attempt to
work across the aisle on important
policy i introduced an amendment that
would have reauthorized nasa's enhanced
use leasing program for one year
a timeline supported by both parties
but to no surprise the democrats put
messaging over good governance and
refused to make this non-controversial
amendment in order
and just a few weeks ago
we had a bipartisan eul bill that had
already passed this house
it was stolen from us
gutted and turned into a federal
election takeover bill
instead of focusing on common sense
solutions to our china problems
uh h.r 4521 hurts the american people it
lets china off the hook
for failing to contain covet 19. it
fails to ban funding to ccp
tied organizations it fails to punish
the ccp for its blatant human rights
abuses and it fails to stop china's
theft of america's intellectual property
today we had another opportunity to pass
important legislation to support
american technology and to hold foreign
adversaries accountable